What is it like?
The city mobile of the future?
Maybe like BMW's latest concept scooter.
The C1-E electric drive.
BMW launched the original C1 back in 1999 but stopped production of their scooter in 2003...
...due to poor sales.
Now, electric drive and the C1-E is to provide the breakthrough.
BMW claims that the electric power of six to seven kilowatts is sufficient for about 100 kilometers.
An important feature carried over from the original model is the much praised safety concept...
...with its seatbelt, safety cell, and roll bar.
And now, the scooter looks sleeker and even more elegant than ever.
BMW is presenting the C1-E as a special contribution to the eSum European safety project...
...where cities such as Rome, Barcelona, Paris and London,...
...ideal places for a two-wheeler, are cooperating with BMW and Piaggio.
The significant increase in sales produced already shows that riding a scooter in large cities...
...has a great future.
And being completely free of noise and exhaust emissions,...
...the electric scooter certainly has a good potential.
While BMW is not yet looking at series production of the C1-E,...
....the concept vehicle is already perfectly prepared for production.